all right let's check in with our caller
from the five-seven for area code who is
calling today from 574 hi david thanks
for taking my call my name is andre big
fan of the channel so a couple days ago
you had a caller that called in and
talked about the VP pick with Bernie
potentially getting nominated and you
guys talked about policy being a pick
and you mentioned that she would be a
terrible picking you expand on that and
explain why you think that would be the
case and what would be some your ideal
VP pick for Bernie ticket yeah so listen
we don't need to read Judah Kate tell
C's entire platform but I although to
you know it's very often said tulsi
endorsed Bernie in 2016 so their
politics are the same they're not
they're very different their foreign
policy views are different their
positions on health care are as we found
out are very different so you know I
want Bernie's VP to be someone not who
is going to maybe appeal to some few
Republicans in the way that Tulsi does
or whatever I really want someone who's
committed to the same progressive
platform or very close to it that Bernie
Sanders is now as far as who would be a
good VP choice for Bernie Sanders
honestly I'm not thinking about it yet
and I could not I'm not prepared to give
any names I know people have called in
and they floated a few different names a
lot of people call in and say what about
Bernie Warren together I don't know I
mean right now not even a single boat
has been cast in the Democratic primary
so I'm not really exploring that yet I'm
looking at other things right now but
I'm confident that Bernie will evaluate
a variety of choices and I believe that
he ultimately I could be wrong but I
believe he's ultimately going to choose
someone who's highly aligned with his
politics rather than sort of from a
different wing of the Democratic Party
but I could be wrong okay
that make sense can I can I do one more
follow-up yes sir
so recently in the news the ruling came
down that the Trump tax returns would
have to be turned over for the
investigators and
likelihood of it being challenged in the
Supreme Court do you think the Supreme
Court will take a won't take up the
decision on that and if if they do side
with Trump what kind of damage do you
think that's going to do to the
institution of the Supreme Court so
here's the thing
I assume the Supreme Court if they take
it up will side with Trump and that the
tax returns won't be given to
investigators but here's the thing we
are like 360 days from the election
right at this point in time the I still
believe that the most effective way to
get Donald Trump out and the quickest is
just to defeat him at the ballot box in
November of 2020 because we're under a
year away so Trump even if the tax
returns were turned over to
investigators that doesn't mean that
they're going to the House of
Representatives it doesn't mean that
they're going public so I am trying to
take a pragmatic approach which is
Donald Trump's Supreme Court Supreme
Court that is increasingly made up of
conservative justices and justice is
selected by Trump is unlikely to do what
we want them to do when it comes to
Trump's taxes even if they said they've
got to be released to investigators the
investigators don't make them public
they might leak so I think we don't even
worry about it and we just vote the guy
out in 360 days yeah absolutely I was
just asking more from the standpoint of
not necessarily getting about the
Supreme Court will say when they decide
that Donald Trump doesn't have to turn
over the tax returns if that's what they
do will be that checks and balances
effectively no longer matter because the
president decides who chooses whether
the checks and balances still apply so
it'll be extraordinarily damaging it'll
be extraordinarily damaging but we can
still vote him out in under a year and
that's why they feel so comfortable just
ignoring all the subpoenas that are
coming down with the investigation
absolutely there's been no evidence so
far thank you so much thank you
appreciate it yep hope to hear from you
again that does it for today sorry to
everybody that I didn't get to and I do
see there are 50 or 55 people hopefully
next time we
we'll take calls again